first as joe biden continues to phone it
in and let the press do his campaigning
for him
president trump continues to demonstrate
that regardless what of what the polls
say and you see them they're all over
the place
he remains an unwavering political force
of nature
just over the past 72 hours he has held
massive rallies in ohio
then to wisconsin then he went
live free or die in new hampshire and
then it was up to maine
and today three more stops
in pennsylvania sleepy joe biden
said a little while ago he was he was in
a lid you know what a little garbage can
they put the lid on it they put them
and he saw we had two of these today
but all of the uh trump rallies perhaps
the ones who didn't even attend
i think they actually ended up saying
the most to us
like in the liberal bastion of beverly
[Applause]
hills
[Applause]
i wanted to be there okay i think i got
that video different forms of it
from five different people in uh in la
it was awesome
and then after all of that tonight here
at the white house
president trump returned to swear in his
third nominee as associate justice of
the supreme court
a woman of outstanding intellect and
character
the american people put their trust in
you
and their faith in you as you take up
the task
of defending our laws our constitution
and this country that we all love
we ask god to give you wisdom and
courage
i know you will make us all very
very proud with justice barrett's
confirmation the democrats
are seething that the president and the
republican senate
did what the constitution allows oh
but they're hoping for payback next
tuesday
but they're honestly the same time
they're still freaking out
check this out from the la times biden
operatives are obsessing over the ways
that everything
could go sideways in this unpredictable
election
everybody's anxious said paul begala
longtime advisor to bill and hillary
clinton
we have permanent traumatic stress
disorder we'll
never get over what happened in 2016.
well that's why democrats and their
media lackeys are going to great lengths
to keep you all in the dark about
joe's real plans for america
he's got to agree to give us a list of 5
or 10
or 20 or 30 or 40. gotta have people to
pick from
and if you don't have that list you
can't vote for him you know it's more
than just a pack in the court
he's got to say who's he going to put on
because we can't have
radical left justices that are going to
destroy our nation
now to be fair maybe biden's not telling
us
because he's forgotten his own plans
watch biden's staff quickly swoop in to
shuffle him along during a quickie
escape the basement trip to pennsylvania
here's the deal one of the things that
that is important
is that
keep in mind although they're going to
vote on
uh barrett
i think that's the case that was
terrifying
i'm sorry the fact is
they're papering over a lot in the
democrat party in their quest for power
the far left which used to be pro-worker
and anti-war
is now throwing in with the
pro-outsourcing
pro-war joe biden and on fracking
aoc either knows joe's lying about not
wanting to ban
it or she's making the ultimate devil's
bargain you introduced a bill earlier
this year
that would ban all fracking nationwide
within the next
five years vice president biden's
position on the issue of fracking
has been confusing it sounds like now
he's on the other side of this issue
from you
does it bother you it will be a
privilege to lobby him
should we win the white house but we
need to focus on winning the white house
first
but as usual the voters are pretty good
at
seeing through the hogwash voters we
spoke to in western pennsylvania are
still pretty confused on the former vice
president's position biden in the past
and through the campaign has kind of
gone back and forth in what he wants to
do it's almost like a domino effect and
it could just be
disastrous in my eyes if you know first
a pandemic and then
fracking is banned the majority of
voters we spoke to say
they will be supporting president trump
this time around
because they do feel like his message is
a little clearer
and will be good for their livelihoods
and their future
now this is all going to come down to
one question are americans
more fearful of losing their livelihoods
and freedom
than they are the virus now if the
former is true
enough will choose to bet on four more
years with trump
who fights for the american worker like
there's no tomorrow